Hallo meine Lieben!
Heute machen wir mal ein Bananenbrot! Warum machen wir das?
Da seid nur ihr dran schuld! Denn ich hab euch in der Story gezeigt auf Instagram, dass ich überreife Bananen hab.
Und eigentlich mag ich die wenn sie so sind, dann sind sie nämlich richtig süß.
Aber irgendwie hatt ich keine Lust die jetzt so zu essen!
(H: Ich mag das nicht wenn die so sind!)
Du gar nicht?
(H: Nee, garnicht!)
Oh Hamza wir sind so unterschiedlich und doch so gleich!
(H: Jah! <3)
Auf jeden Fall mach ich daraus jetzt Bananenbrot auf euren Wunsch hin
und ich hab da jetzt so ein paar Zutaten sag ich mal ausgetauscht
damit es etwas "gesünder" ist.
Ich mach das jetzt hier mit der Küchenmaschine, ihr könnt euer Handrührgerät verwenden
und ich geb da jetzt zuallererst Eier hinzu.
Es ist besser, wenn die zimmerwarm sind. Die geb ich jetzt dazu.
(H: Also alle Mengenangaben findet man...)
Alle Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung! Guter Hinweis!
Da geb ich jetzt noch Xylit rein, das ist Birkenzucker, hat 40% weniger Kalorien
als Haushaltszucker. Ihr könntet aber auch 1:1 Haushaltszucker nehmen, den gewöhnlichen,
den ihr kennt.
Geb ich da jetzt auch noch mit dazu.
Dann für den Geschmack Vanilleextrakt und Zimt.
Ich find Zimt passt wunderbar aber ihr könnt den Zimt auch weglassen.
So und dann verrühren wir das 3min lang!
Die Eier-Zucker-Masse wird jetzt 3min lang auf allerhöchster Stufe gemixt,
dann wird sie richtig schön voluminös.
Und ganz zum Schluss geb ich ganz kurz noch das Sonnenblumenöl mit dazu.
Da könntet ihr jetzt auch Rapsöl nehmen oder wenn ihr möchtet
gerne auch Kokosöl.
Und im nächsten Schritt kommt das Mehl mit dazu.
Ich hab jetzt hier Mehl und Backpulver, Mehl ist bei mir ganz normales Weizenmehl.
Für eine noch gesündere Variante könntet ihr z.B. Dinkelmehl nehmen, Typ 630
könnt ihr hier 1:1 ersetzen.
Oder ihr nehmt 1/3 Kokosmehl.
Das könnt ihr auch gerne nehmen, ist auch super gesund.
Also eigentlich gibt's total viele Varianten.
Das ist jetzt hier wie gesagt nur eine.
Das geb ich jetzt noch dazu und siebe das, dann hab ich auch
keine Klümpchen im Teig.
Und das wird dann nur ganz kurz eingerührt.
Im nächsten Schritt geben wir Walnüsse dazu, könnt auch natürlich andere Nüsse nehmen.
Einfach die, die ihr am liebsten mögt.
Danach Chocolate Chunks in Zartbitter.
Ich liebe diese dicken fetten Chocolate Chunks Stücke!
Und anschließend noch lauwarme Milch, die könntet ihr natürlich auch schon vorher dazugeben,
- das war jetzt mein Fehler, das hab ich einfach vergessen -
aber das macht dem Teig jetzt keinen Abbruch, also dem Geschmack vor allem nicht!
Und da geben wir jetzt auch noch kleingeschnittene Bananen rein.
Wie gesagt: Meiner Meinung nach je reifer, desto besser!
Die geb ich jetzt aber nur noch mit meinem Teigschaber in den Teig
und dann können wir ihn auch schon backen, unser Bananenbrot!
So, jetzt schnappen wir uns eine Kastenkuchenform - ich verlink euch meine unten in die Videobeschreibung -
und füllen den Teig ein.
Davor geb ich ganz gerne noch Backpapier rein, damit man's ganz einfach leichter rausbekommt.
Gerne noch vorher mit ein bisschen Backtrennspray einsprühen, dann haftet das auch wunderbar!
Und was ihr unbedingt machen müsst, mein Tipp für euch:
Schnappt euch ein bisschen braunen Zucker oder Rohrzucker und gebt das ganz dünn
auf die Oberfläche, dann karamellisiert das und ihr habt so ne Art Kruste,
obwohl ihr gar nichts dafür machen musstet!
Also wirklich nur ein bisschen Zucker drüber streuen!
Und für die Optik und  damit man auch weiß, worum es sich handelt,
noch eine Banane einmal durchschneiden in der Mitte und oben in den Teig reindrücken.
Und jetzt backen wir unser Bananenbrot bei 180 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze für ca 45-50min,
eventuell auch 55min, da müsst ihr einfach selber schauen.
Macht gerne die Stäbchenprobe und falls euch das zu dunkel wird,
gebt einfach ein bisschen Alufolie auf die Oberfläche und dann kann euch da eigentlich nichts schief gehen!
Wir sehen uns gleich wieder!
Und fertig ist das Bananenbrot! Oah, das riecht so gut! Das riecht so, so gut!
Ihr könnt das jetzt entweder zum Frühstück mit nem Belag drauf, z.B. Schokocreme -
richtig lecker! - Mit Schokocreme oder einfach so ohne alles zum Kaffee oder zum Tee,
ihr könnt's essen wie ihr möchtet!
Und ihr habt auch hier diese leckere Kruste durch den Rohrzucker,
das können wir jetzt gerne mal zeigen... das hört man glaub ich auch!
Also die leckere Kruste und innen ist es halt eher so ein bisschen softer
und das hält sich jetzt auch wenn ihr's luftdicht verpackt so ca. 3-4 Tage.
Ganz frisch schmeckt es natürlich am allerbesten!
Wie gesagt die genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in der Videobeschreibung,
einmal aufklappen, anschauen und dann einkaufen gehen.
Und ansonsten abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos, dann verpasst ihr auch nichts mehr,
hinterlasst ein Däumchen nach oben und dann lesen wir hier unten in den Kommentaren voneinander,
wir schreiben miteinander.
Und sehen uns dann bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüüss!